[Music]
greetings of peace welcome to the dean
shaw met your host and if you haven't
subscribed subscribe
right now we have an exciting show for
you as always did you know
that for a century jews and muslims live
together in
peace now i know many of you have been
taught otherwise
or some people have actually been
brainwashed to believe otherwise but we
have
a chief rabbi of 30 years
here in the d show to give us the facts
not
fiction of the beautiful relationship
that jews and muslims had
and to this day are working together for
good
against a force that has hijacked
judaism and is hiding behind it
and is tyrannically oppressing a certain
group of people out there we're going to
be talking about this
again facts not fiction here on the d
show
don't go anywhere very exciting show
with my next guest
be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the danger
greetings and peace thank you for being
with us here on the dean show
and you heard me open the show time is
short but
you know the dean shows out there clear
misconceptions you know helping to
enlighten the minds and and one of the
myths that many people have nowadays
is that muslims you know you know
muslims and jews
you know there there was never us any
kind of uh
you know collaboration any goodness that
jews you know were persecuted by muslims
they didn't live together in peace you
know what i mean
and that's why this state had to come
into existence to protect
the jewish people what do you have to
say about this uh
there's such a a crucial issue it's such
a
really we i pray to the almighty first
that he should bestow upon me his truth
his wisdom
that i may be worthy of conveying his
message and so sanctify
his name and bring peace to the world
domain and it's it
in such a short time to be able to uh
uh express all the issues here to
explain all the issues here will be very
hard
but we'll try with god's help just to at
least shine a light on what we're having
here
it is true it is a fact that jews lived
and flourished in the muslim and arab
lands and anybody who would like to
see for themselves go to uh tunisia
morocco
um iran egypt and um and
yemen and all the lands there and prior
to any human rights groups to protect
uh prior you can just go you can find
the synagogues
uh that were there until recent uh
recent
times and some of them still exist in
iran they still they are there people
are practicing the religion there the
jewish religion
uh but um until recently until zionism
came about
jews flourished as distinctly religious
jewish communities
and they were massacred on the contrary
they went to these arab muslim lands
to escape persecution uh from the
crusades from the inquisition and from
many other trials and tribulations and
the um and even world war ii
uh the arab muslim lands opened their
hearts opened their lands
and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious hospitality for the jewish
people
again clearly they we have different
religion
um and yet uh we were
we were accepted in these muslim and
arabs we believe in one god and we were
accepted we have different ways
of serving god but yet as i
they we were respected and the even the
muslim religion requires of that
of the uh the muslim people to
to provide protection and hospitality
and they did
carry that out that's clear nobody could
refute this fact
although unfortunately zionism and the
zionist
uh zionists try constantly to vilify
the muslim people and try to recreate
a scenario of as if we have some
deep embedded religious conflict and a
hate
between jews and muslims and that is so
deplorable despicable and really it's
the words it's an aqua
and let me try to explain really people
have to understand you know i
threw in words zionism and this what
we're talking about here yeah
what is it most people are ignorant now
when you hear zionism
you know what's the difference between
judaism and zionism yeah
uh with god's help the judaism
is a religion it's it is the covenant
that jewish people made some 3000 years
ago
on mount sinai uh to be subservient to
god
and to follow the laws of the torah 613
commandments in the torah
we in the torah is full of laws that are
replete some
a large segment of them have to do with
keeping sabbath kosher things that
pertain from
us as human beings to the almighty and
then there is a large segment of the
torah that pertains to that one
should not steal and will not kill and
to be compassionate and so forth
um it's all there's many many
commandments it's all part and parcel of
the torah
in fact uh we can encompass it as one of
the
commands one of the statements is that
um
that in hebrew it says
just as god is compassionate you should
be compassionate
so basically that is what judaism is
zionism
is a mere hundred odd years it was a
movement of jews
who were estranged in the torah the
testator and tried to transform
this judaism into where zach's judaism a
new judaism which is pure
nationalism material concept having an
army uh
olympic team and to be a nation proud
amongst other nations
totally removing in its essence uh the
concept of godliness removing god from
uh
from the equation and they will allow
religion they say
or how far they do or don't but they are
have hijacked the name israel they've
hijacked
the whole uh judaism to
legitimize and to put a facade of that
it's kosher that it's uh
godly what they're doing when in truth
it contradicts judaism and it's totally
forbidden and i'll explain why
can you before we go to break so can you
be a a can you be jewish and an atheist
of course not it's ridiculous that
judaism is belief in god that's what
it's all about a covenant with god
it's not a nationalism it's not some
type of a country that you can be
a democrat you can be a marxist or
something
while zionism exactly is exactly that
they were marxists and they
claim to be democrats and they proudly
claim that they're that they
you don't have to be a practicing jew
and and and to be a good jew as long as
you're supporting the state so that
in of itself shows the heresy and the
blasphemy and what this
is but there's much more to what we're
talking ab the issue of zionism and i
would
really have to elaborate a little bit on
what this is uh on on what zionism how
in every facet
it rebels against god and it um it it is
uh
uh it is rooted in heresy and in in
non-belief in god and in doing evil
basically
uh before we go to break just one more
thing it really touched
a lot of the hearts when people have
heard you say that jews and muslims at
one point when they were living before
this
this whole nationalistic atheistic
movement zionism
is it safe to say that's what it is an
atheistic nationalistic movement
so now before that uh they were actually
babysitting each other's kids
so if you're leaving a kid with someone
your own you know flesh and blood your
your joy of your heart you know this is
not your enemies the most precious of
the possession that a person has it's
what god gave a person and jews and
muslims will leave their kids they live
in the same courtyards we have many jews
who are alive today to
to thank god and they lived in the old
courtyards in in old jerusalem to
testify
and they could testify this and uh to
this uh uh
both from the arab muslim people and the
jewish communities i have many
colleagues about we're going to take a
break
and we're going to talk about a lot more
here in the dean show with rabbi weiss
don't go anywhere misconception muslims
are
terrorists this is by far the biggest
misconception of islam
given unfairly by stereotyping in the
public image that the media gives
has anyone else noticed how when a
specific group of people attack another
group of people it is labeled as a hate
crime
but when a muslim opens fire on anybody
it is quickly regarded as terrorism
many political dictators and officials
or extremist groups
use the name of islam as a strategy to
garner followers and attention
when many of their practices go against
the true basis of islam
the media has also portrayed islam as a
cult or club
where if you join you become a terrorist
and that is now part of your agenda
however all over the world people
practice islam in the true form and use
it as a way of life
there are many verses in the quran that
go against the idea of terrorism
some of these verses include fight the
way of allah those that fight you but do
not transgress limits for god does not
love transgressors
this basically means do not fight except
in self-defense
and even in doing so do not go beyond
defense another verse states
if they seek peace then you seek peace
which means do not attack people for no
reason or kill innocent people
there is nowhere in islam whether it be
in the quran or the teachings of
muhammad that promotes the killing of
innocent people
please subscribe to the d show follow us
on our official facebook and twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the show by
making a donation in the link below
back here on the dean show with rabbi
weiss rabbi of 30 years we're talking
about
clearing up you know some of the
misconceptions the myths
and many people again we are talking
about zionism what this actually is
we're clearing out what judaism is
and the difference between the two
please continue from there
oh with the help of the almighty um as i
was
saying earlier judaism is subservience
to god and to
to strictly adhere to the laws of the
torah that god made a covenant with us
on mount sinai we must uphold the torah
that is what judaism is
nothing less nothing more that's what it
is a judaism
and zionism is this
new relatively new movement because it's
a hundred ideas while judaism is three
thousand years
and what it is a total transformation
internationalism
and um in first of all it's rooted in
heresy in blasphemy what it states is uh
that we have to take a gun to protect us
where was god
by the second world war although zionism
started before the second but they
they say we have we have to protect
ourselves and they they they constantly
harp on this issue and that uh our only
salvation is with the gun um and totally
ignoring
the fact that which our salvation as a
jew what a jew means
is to look to god for protection to
to understand that god rules the world
but
there's much more than that um
judaism clearly states in the uh
prophecies when that we were living in
the holy land
um at the time uh there was king david
and then king salman built the temple
and then there was a there was the
prophets uh jeremiah ezekiel
isaiah all of them and they kept on
warning the jews that they have to be on
this high level of holiness
and if not they will be expelled from
the land and this happened with the
destruction
of the temple two thousand odd years ago
and um
uh at that time king solomon
had wrote in a prophecy in the book
called shara sheeran's song of songs
uh he wrote the jews on the three oaths
one that since we were expelled and sent
into exile
again clearly as a jew believes it not
because of our physical lacking only
because our
because it was a decree of god because
of our spiritual lacking
therefore god said put us on the three
oaths one not to return in mass in large
numbers to the holy land
jews were living as private individuals
under different under turkey or whoever
it was
that the ottoman republic is all fine
but to create to
in return in mass that is forbidden if
um
secondly we are not to rebuild against
any nation we're not to
make any attempt um to to we have to be
loyal citizens in every country pray for
the
for the uh well-being of the country
that we're residing in
thirdly not to make any attempt to end
exile
so this jews respected for 2000 as we
went through the inquisition
the spanish inquisition we went through
so many trials and tribulations
and yet the jews had the opportunity
there was rich times the golden age of
jew they had
money to buy a piece of land and they
didn't because it is expressly forbidden
meaning that even if they would have
been in a desolate land uninhabited
jews respected the fact that we should
not buy one piece
of land to make jewish sovereignty this
was respected for two thousand years
now the zionists came and they created a
state ignoring totally
and laughing at what the teachings of
the torah and
ridiculing the ones who followed this
this belief in the torah which is pure
the 101 of judaism and they said we was
god to protect us they
they they simply uh uh um discredit god
and the torah and therefore they said
we're going to make a state
and and to pro as supposedly for
protection of whatever reason
at the same time this is not enough but
the fact that they made their state in a
land that was inhabited it wasn't a
desolate land there wasn't
a a a a an uninhabited land it wasn't
that's a myth there it was that they
used to say that mantra was it was a
land without a people of people without
a land so now they decided to create
this state in a land that was inhabited
the majority the vast majority were
muslim then there was a christian
community and it was a jewish community
all three of these communities were
uh anti-zionist because the jews which
were in almost its entirety they were
the religious communities
and this zionism came from europe with
the backing of
britain and so forth and they decided to
create the state
so it it it really it breached the laws
and the commands of god in
every facet again we are forbidden to
have a state and on top of that
it's clear the torah is repeat as i've
said with do not kill do not steal
um um and and to show there's a com the
commandos that we have to we have to
show
gratitude for people that have done good
to us and the muslim countries were the
ones and the arab countries the ones
who provided a home for jews and now to
go and vilify these people
and and claim that they hate jews and
their anti-semites
and so forth this is so repugnant by us
it is such
a tragedy and humiliation for us because
not only are they creating this state
they're and and but they're doing it by
vilifying the people that were good to
us so in every
and they're using my name they've
hijacked the name israel
and all our uh symbols the menorah the
the
star of david and and so and and they
put on a facade of religion they claim
it's a jewish state they claim it's
um the state of israel and they have
these rabbis so-called rabbis who they
who they were able to get always a bad
apple in a barrel
they were able to get a few we have tens
of thousands of rabbis we've had
especially before the second world war
um and they were able to green a few for
a few dollars or whatever they did
and they were able to get a few and they
use these and make them big and they and
and
and these people um as a lawyer would be
able
to you know twist the case
a gifted lawyer so these rabbis although
they know the torah some of them some of
them don't
but they made what they do is they
simply
twisted the torah and then the talmud
and the torah warned us that
just as like you're not a jew is not
allowed to eat a worm it's just like
we're not
eating pig so there's staying sailing
and
saying in the talmud there's 150 ways
to prove that you can eat a worm
although it's clear in the torah with
not a lot it's a verse of the torah
in other words they're trying to say
that you can twist anything if you'd
like
if you want to twist something so
they've taken these supposed rabbis they
made a rabbinate a chief rabbi
and it's all a farce and it's a facade
and they and it
just representing this uh hypocrisy
called the state of israel
which is totally non-religious they they
they detest religion they made it
they they called a democracy not a
religion
and so in every facet this is
contradictory to judaism
and all the rabbinical authorities with
god's help will show you
especially the chief rabbis of palestine
now you said uh chief rabbi at that time
before this was formed right he went to
the united nations and what yes
and we have a book called traditional
torah opposition to zionism and in 1947
the year before the
state of israel was ratified and the
chief rabbi of palestine
turned to the united nations we have all
the pictures of it we have all the
um what he said you know just one
statement we furthermore
this is rabbi duchinsky of the chief
rabbi of palestine
of the ashkenazi community and there was
esparadic rabbis also they said we
furthermore wish to express
our definite opposition to a jewish
state
in any part of palestine this was a
declaration before the united nations
july 16 1947
four months later when they saw they
were being ignored he again turned to
the uh he sent a communication
to the secretary general of the united
nations like success
and he said um the jewish orthodox
community called
this god-fearing community because the
others he said of jerusalem comprising
60 000 souls objects to the plea of
including jerusalem
in the jewish state or its residents
becoming automatically citizens of the
jewish state
our community demands that jerusalem be
an international international zone
under your protection
with full autonomy residency free
citizens so basically what's this uh
we have to go to break so if somebody
wants to google his name
his name was rabbi um joseph
james authority of the jews at that time
he represented the jewish community
and um you can even in the united
nations we have the pictures where he
sat with uh it's in the united nations
document
he wasn't the only one across the board
we have the rabbi speak out 130 years of
religious jewish opposition designers
and the greatest
yeah your grandparents were actually
holocaust survivors my grandparents were
killed in auschwitz my father escaped
went to italy came to the united states
and he was actually a follower of
one of the greatest torah authorities in
in europe um
uh and his name was they called the mean
catcher from a city called
and rabbi shapiro and he was a
great um a great torito and he was most
one of the most vociferous against
zionism
but we have many like the rabbi joseph
um you saw mayor cohen called the
hovertrain who wrote
everybody recognized him as the greatest
like one of the greatest qualifiers of
jewish was before the war
and in every community they recognized
him and he said he said he said i'm
quoting him therefore every man
the zionists are dead rims of our people
which would cause the entire body to rat
and omar and the ambassador paragraph
16.
we're going to take a break but these
are all chief rabbis leaders greatest
leaders of the jewish
people its entirety there was very you
can count on the hand
the zionists when they came to be uh
in europe and all in in the other
communities in palestine
the jewish communities threw them out
they they totally uh um ostracized them
they didn't
zionism was not acceptable in any manner
shape or form in judaism
here with uh rabbi weiss we're going to
take a a break peace activists calling
for peace
and muslims and jews working together
for peace we'll be right back
here on the dean's show please subscribe
to the d show follow us on our official
facebook and twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the d show by
making a donation in the link below
[Music]
back here on the dean show with rabbi
weiss now
usually when people come out and they
say anything
they'll get a backlash and people say
look you're anti-semitic
right or if even a rabbi such as
yourself and we see right now we're
seeing pictures was i think there was
like
50 000 jews
many rabbis you know you can see the
pictures right now
coming out and this is in new york and
they're
staunchly against this movement that has
been responsible for
terrorism and terrifying people innocent
people children
and whatnot so what do you say what do
you have to say when someone
you know uses these things these uh
these these nasty words yeah i'm happy
that you brought this up because
unfortunately the world thinks that the
more the jewish you are the more
religious you are the more zionist you
are
in fact it is just the opposite of
anybody if they will give take the
effort
they will see that invariably whether it
is in jerusalem and al quotes
in in in wherever there is a very
religious community in stamford hills in
london with the most religious jewish
community or in new york if you just
across from manhattan it's called
williamsburg brooklyn
uh and um and i can go on wherever
around the world
the most the more religious the more
anti-zionist because as i've explained
it's zionism is totally contradictory
it's it's really
antithetical to jews it just two cannot
meet it's impossible
judaism subservience to god zionism is
rebelling against god
in every facet now the zionists being
that they don't have the
uh the the godly uh of
fear of god and the the the this
morals of given by god of how one should
uh live his life therefore they have no
compunctions
with using the jew judaism as a facade
and a
stick to intimidate others that they
wave the the the bible and they use this
emotional music
oh we were 2 000 years in exile and now
we finally got back the land we're
continuation of king david
and to us this we could vomit from this
listening to this because so despicable
because
everybody if you would just follow their
lives they they in the
the con the whole state of israel is uh
breaches
all the ten commandments and everything
of the torah they don't um keep they
desecrate the sabbath they they they
they um uh they they they have
non-kosher foods that they
have pigs and and um and everything they
they um
dig up graves for archaeological
purposes they
um and they and i go on and on they do
forced autopsy but not only that they
brutally beat the jews who are religious
jews they detest
religious jews um um i just may say a
statement
well theodore herzl in in in traditional
torah opposition to zionism
uh theodor herzl um uh wrote that the
solution
and i have this in this we have some of
their statements
he said um i'll quote him uh in his own
diary
uh the way to solve the problem of
anti-semitism is to speak to the head
priest of vienna
to get an appointment with the pope to
make a mass conversion of all the jews
of wall street to catholicism
that was his solution it should be done
on a sunday in the middle of the day
with music and pride publicly
we are the last generation that held on
to the faith of our forefathers
jews gave their lives for their religion
throughout the history
and he says oh we'll just drop it with
music and run private
and he himself carried out his was he
had one son and he announced publicly
that he's not circumcising his son the
thing that jews gave their lives for
there was one zev jabatinski also one of
the fathers of the ergun
there was a prime minister called bagan
he was his mentor everybody knows
who follow zionism and he wrote in an
article in 1919
what book is this again a traditional
torah opposition to zionism
zionism it's historic documents
document.nkusa.org you can find
your website our website you can find
and he wrote an
uh openly in a newspaper in in the
called the hadasha's hearts that means
the news of the land
he wrote in 1919 um
in the national home we will announce
that the jews those jews who have on
themselves the rust of exile and they
refuse to shave off their beards
and airlocks pay us it's called will be
second class citizens
and will not have the right to vote now
imagine that if an
arab person would say this a muslim
country would say that they the zionists
would be all over them
and say how do you do it and they're the
protectors of
the jewish people around the world this
is their hypocrisy what they are
but um but but not only that the jewish
people we're never militant we're not
we're not armed we don't carry arms
and yet when we have all simply to voice
our opposition to the zionist
occupation of palestine and what they're
doing we have demonstrations now who are
who are these uh people these are rabbis
some of them are rabbis some of them are
layman just jews are these
these are zionists these are the muslims
these are the
zionist the police the soldiers the
zionists are beating they're
brutally beating them we have we have
reams and memes of pictures that can go
to our side nk usa and there's
links you can see we have as you've
mentioned we have demonstrations that
never get covered because of their
intimidation
around the world that you're
anti-semitic if you oppose them so
newspapers fear the fear of to
dare speak up against the zionism or to
show any uh uh
sympathy for the palestinian because we
here we have tens of thousands of jews
when
netanyahu came to visit president obama
we have as you said in new york we have
we have every year we have many times
that there's
there's tens of thousands of jews saying
that we are against the existence
the mere existence of this rebellion
against god called the zionist state of
israel
we don't accept it it's unacceptable to
god not we don't accept it it's
unacceptable because we are jews
because we are jews we we we oppose the
existence
of the state of israel our we we
sympathize
we cry with the people of palestine for
in their suffering and what happens
in palestine this is what happens in
palestine we get brutally
these are israeli soldiers this is what
they do day in and day out we get
arrested we get brutally
we get our leaders we're assassinated
and and and
this is the chief rabbi of palestine
today um but nothing to do again with
the zionist
rabbinate or that chief rabbi which is a
facade it's just window dressing and
that they should be able to carry out
whatever they need to do
rip up aloe vera so they have
a signed by their rabbis their rabbis
may have no
be knowledgeable but that doesn't mean
it's neither here nor there it's nothing
because they are not upholding the torah
they are not only not
rabbis but they are not practitioners of
judaism they've
excluded themselves from the jew from
judaism and um
and we have so many um again
people could see pictures of the tens
and tens of thousands of people
demonstrating these pictures are not big
enough to go to the site
whether it is in washington whether it
is in new york whether it is in
um in palestine mostly in london around
the world we demonstrate
we will also go we as jews who are true
to judaism
we went to gaza we we met we go to
muslim countries now perhaps
because it's a requirement as the chief
rabbi of palestine robert title bound
said
we are required to let the world know
that these
zionists and their state does not speak
for the jewish people and they are not
um
in any way have the right to use judaism
to oppress to steal the land from the
palestinian people
uh these people who are good to us and
we babysit each other's children we
live together they have no right to
steal from them the torah doesn't permit
you to steal
and here we went to gaza we brought um
uh uh just recently we sent an ambulance
we couldn't go recently to um because of
what's happening we usually go through
egypt but unfortunately what's happening
but we sent from norway we
and together with the people from noah
we brought an ambulance we went to twice
they'll be after the attacks on gaza two
a few years ago
and here we're meeting we're
non-political so we're good with all the
factions with president abbas and with
the
um and the prime minister this is
meeting with prime minister
ishmael khania in in uh in gaza and we
meet within and we went to the iran and
to um
and and all the people and the kings and
the leaders thank god
to tell them that the people should
understand that there is not
the religion isn't the issue zionist
wants to confuse to make it that is a
religious conflict
nothing to do with religion the on the
contrary the muslims and the arab people
were for us our friends and our patrons
the ones who protect us and provide a
safe haven
and they should not be full full
victim of this evil movement of zionism
with god's help if you
remove this impediment to peace
zionism a new a relatively new ideology
so a hundred mere years
then the jews and muslims and christians
were living for hundreds and hundreds of
years and it was never a problem
we could just remove that little drop of
sand that was thrown in the person in
the in the eye
he can't that dropped that zionism
remove that impediment to peace
it and and don't be confused that you
have to remove this religion these
people followers of
practice of religion the world
unfortunately confuses these
issues and that is where the problem is
and that's why there's no light at the
end of the tunnel because they feel that
they have to
force this zionism that it should
continue
remove it and you won't have to put in
billions of dollars for building
walls and everything because we can live
together as history
so beautifully attest to the fact that
we live together i'd like to thank you
we're out of time
we have to go moving forward how can
people if they want to get you know
sincere people out there
who want to know the truth but there's a
lot of confusion over this
how can they get more informed well with
god's help they again
they can go to our site www.nkusa.org
and as um in november
um nkusa.org and
uh there's a lot of sites links they can
go to that we urge people
don't quote a jewish state called
zionist state you shouldn't get
fall into the trap of being referred to
and we urge people
both to pray to the almighty who
ultimately is the one who brings the
results
and do not be silent don't be do not be
intimidated stand up for the people of
gaza and palestine
to urge the leaders just as south africa
was
stopped from from the apartheid we can
with god's help we will be able to by
having and putting pressure on our
politicians that they should understand
they have to stop this injustice and
with we plead with people invite us and
let us know of conferences around the
world
um and bring us there we do not charge
honorariums we have to tell godly
obligation to educate the world
to understand that there is a way out of
this terrible terrible knock with this
tragedy
simply by removing this impediment to
peace
god helps speedily peacefully uh and
soon in our days
and then we could live together in peace
and harmony in peace thank you so much
thank you very much for being with us
here on the dean show rabbi thank you
thank you
and that was rabbi weiss as you can see
jews and muslims
lived it's a fallacy that they didn't
live together in peace
that they actually babysat each other's
kids and the rabbi had mentioned
apartheid
now i'm going to end with this quote
from nelson mandela
where he mentioned that stated that a
part-time is a crime against humanity
israel has deprived millions of
palestinians of their liberty
and prosperity property it has
perpetuated a system of gross radical
discrimination
and equality has systematically
incarcerated and tortured thousands of
palestinians
contrary to the rules of international
law it has
in particular waged a war against a
civilian population
in particular children in particular
innocent children
get informed get enlighted and don't be
someone who's just blindly hating
and connect with god connect with your
creator ask him for the guidance he'll
make it clear we'll see you next time on
the d
show subscribe if you haven't already
follow us
on the social media tools and we'll see
you next time until then peace be
on to you